you came out with a with a calendar yeah
and I love this this is a you are doing
you're recreating iconic photographs
that were done by a very well-known
artist what was the artists that you're
recreating yeah Colin and Gettys &
Geddes yes
yeah and Geddes you recreated you
recreated some of her iconic shots for
your own calendar oh yes no I have a
question you're coming out with this
calendar right now it's July who comes
out with a calendar in July
exactly Conan O'Brien ha ha cornering
markets what are you talking about who
is purchasing right now you are sitting
in your water your kitchen you're having
a little sippy of cappuccino and you
look at your calendar that was I don't
know what it is have kittens or perhaps
like Aaron's cousins yeah boring time
for new calendar the Flula calendar so
you're saying in July is a good time to
switch it up
hello switcher switcher ok let's take a
look at some of these shots that you've
done these are beautiful there you are
yeah coming out of flower pot so that's
me all of those are me so yeah yeah no I
know they you can do that trick
photography is your right will know
about this yes a lot of people know
about let's say the next one right here
let's see oh yeah where you worry you're
just a little cabbage naked cabbage boys
ah yes okay sure some cabbage some
cabbie we had of nibbling I ate some of
those medicines okay and then what's
next I just want to see what the next
one is oh yeah that's shot spooning is
very important okay this is some as you
would say hi bear nation do you get it
because of beer
you're no longer welcome back okay you
can't come back
you